VYACHESLAV EGOROV: Can you
hear me, because I'm not sure--
OK, I can hear myself.
So that's good.
I was so stressed
configuring the resolution,
so I didn't hear how
they introduced me.
So my name is Vyacheslav.
I work on the Dart VM team.
And I'm here to give a slightly
different talk from what
you have been listening to for
the past two or three hours,
I guess.
Originally, I wanted to give
the talk title like that.
But I figured out
that it will take
around one hour, if not two.
So let's limit ourselves to
some small domain, like mobile,
which is kind of quite hot,
as you have figured out
from the previous talks,
that Flutter is everywhere.
And if Flutter is
everywhere, the Dart
is everywhere as well, so.
This is a talk about Dart VM,
because I work on Dart VM.
But before we actually get
into nitty gritty details,
it's good to establish
what Dart VM actually is.
Because when you
talk to people, you
discover that they don't
know what Dart VM is.
And when they deploy a
Flutter app, is Dart VM--
is it used, even?
No, maybe not.
In reality, there are
a lot of components
that Dart VM provides.
And I put some of
them on the slide.
I tried to fit as
much as I could.
But I'm sure I
have omitted some.
And they can be split into
three groups, roughly.
The runtime components--
like garbage collection,
for example.
Then there is some compilers
that provide compilation
to native code.
I put Interpreter also in the
compiler for certain reasons.
And then there are developer
productivity components,
which provide things
like hot reload,
debugging, and profiling.
And depending on how you mix
and match these components
together, you get
different results.
For example, if you have
this artisanally-crafted,
iPhone-like looking
thing there, and you
are developing a mobile
application using Flutter, then
in the development mode
or so-called slow mode,
you have some runtime and
compilation components
and the developer
experience components
all running on the host device.
So that's how we provide this
high-fidelity hot reload,
for example, because the
device can do everything.
It can reload the code.
It can JIT it or execute
it on the interpreter,
depending whether you are
running on Android or iOS.
And you can profile it
as well, for example.
So everything is
running on the device.
If you are releasing your
application to the users,
like through the app
stores, then what you do
is that, on the host, on
you development machine,
you compile it-- using, again,
some components from the Dart
VM runtime system and some
components from the Dart VM
compilation pipelines.
And then you ship
Dart VM runtime,
which still contains
garbage collector
and other auxiliary components,
plus the ahead-of-time compiled
code to the host devices.
So the Dart VM is
still in the picture,
even if you are releasing
your application to the users.
So ultimately, that means
that with all your questions
about optimizing
Dart code for users,
you have to come to the
Dart VM people and ask them.
So what if you have
such a question?
What should you do?
Well, I have two answers
to this question.
The first answer is that you
should always use Observatory,
right?
There are some great tutorials
for how to do it on the site.
And there are other
talks about this
from the previous Dart cons.
So you should watch them.
And another is that you
should always talk to us.
If you see something suspicious
in the VM, you just come to us.
And we fix it for you.
That's our modus operandi.
And I actually wanted to
finish the talk here, because--
well, that's it.
That's all that you
have to know, really.
But when I did the dry
run, somehow Philip
was not very impressed
by that suggestion.
So I will keep on
trucking and tell you
more interesting stuff.
So the reason why I really
wanted to finish it here
is that I don't want to
promulgate this idea that I
can give you 10 suggestions.
And then you go, and replace
all your forEach invocations
with a for loop in you code,
and suddenly, everything
is going to be fixed.
The performance is
not a cargo cult,
where you can just follow
some suggestions blindly.
You need to understand
what you are doing.
And you need to understand
your application
as much as you understand
the underlying platform.
And this is very important.
So that's why I
really don't want
to limit this talk to
just some suggestions.
And another reason
is that, if you
look at the timeline of
Dart, and if you listen
to the talks that were
given here before,
you should have figured out
that, in the past two years,
there was a paradigm shift
in the Dart language.
And it's not a small
paradigm shift.
It's a really big
[LAUGHTER]
And it obviously has certain
consequences on the performance
of the Dart language.
There is such thing
as strong mode.
And there is the
limitations on the integers.
And there is the changes
to the infrastructure.
So let's look at how Dart
operated seven years ago.
If you go back in time and
you watch some presentations
about Dart when
it was announced,
you will discover that
there is such statements,
that "by default,
type annotations have
no effect and no cost."
And this is a certainly
valid statement.
But it turns out that cost
is a very complicated thing.
Like, they don't have a cost?
And what the original
authors meant here
is that it doesn't
cost you anything
to check certain values
of a certain type,
because there is
no need to check.
Everything just keeps on
trucking without any checks.
But it turns out that you
cannot actually do any useful
optimizations ahead of time
if you cannot trust your type
annotations.
So this is a valid Dart
code from the Dart 1
And you have a cat
and you have a dog.
And both of them can woof.
It's a very strange cat.
And you write a function
which expects to do with dogs,
and the cat sneaks in.
And everything works
just fine, because that's
how Dart 1 operates.
It doesn't force you to write
meaningful type annotations.
And it can work without
it, reasonably efficient.
But it turns out that
this is confusing
in the ahead-of-time compilation
context, like, for example,
iOS.
Or like when you
deploy Flutter, you're
forced to do the
ahead-of-time compilation.
So we came up with a
solution that for Dart 1
allows the ahead-of-time
compiled code executed
relatively efficiently.
Here's a solution.
I promised the talk
will be different.
So I put some ARM
assembly on the slides.
Let me try to explain it a
little bit easier than ARM
assembly.
So this pig nose here is
actually not that pig nose.
It's a power socket.
And into power socket, you
can plug different plugs.
And that's what
switchable calls are,
in the ahead-of-time
compiler in Dart.
So for each invocation in your
ahead-of-time compiled code,
we generate two slots some
way, or in some auxiliary data
structure, where one slot
contains the piece of code
that will be called when
you reach this invocation.
And there is some
metadata on the site.
And these two slots can
be updated independently
as the application is running.
And it allows the
ahead-of-time compiled code
to adapt to what's actually
happening in your application,
whether it's the cats that
are woofing or it's the dogs.
Or it may be some
seagulls, and so on.
So here's how it works.
So first, when you just
start your application--
all the methods,
they know nothing.
All the dynamically-dispatched
methods, they know nothing.
And then as the application
runs-- for example,
if it saw only cats woofing--
then it would just put enough
information in these slots
to do a direct invocation.
And if you suddenly
get some dogs woofing,
then it will switch what
it does in those slots
to do a call that searches some
list for the invocation target,
and so on and so forth.
There is even a
case when if there
is too much different strange
animals going around, then
it will use some sort of
a hash table on the site,
and use the search
in the hash table.
So this approach allows
you to reduce the overhead
of each individual dispatch.
But you can see that the
call is still present there.
And this means that across
these code boundaries,
you cannot eliminate
any redundancies,
which might or might not be
important for your application,
right?
For some applications,
you really need to--
for some types of
code, you really
need to know what is being
called in each particular call
site to produce the
most efficient code.
A good example of
such code is code
that does a lot of mathematics.
I don't know how
common mathematics is.
But it definitely sometimes
occurs in the code.
And it's not limited
to the double math.
It can be also just
some bitwise math
as well, when you are
unpacking some protobuf
or some binary format.
So I wrote this code here
doing some harmonic series.
Doesn't really matter
what it's doing.
It's doing a lot of math.
And then I wrote
some benchmark that
just translates in the loop
and says how long it takes.
And then I put it in the debug
mode Flutter on my Nexus 5X.
And in debug mode, it
took 3,000 milliseconds.
OK, this number does not
tell us anything, because we
don't have any expectations.
Here's a question--
how long do we
think the release mode takes?
Because release mode is the one
that doesn't have a slow mode
banner.
Like, let's say, is
it two times faster?
Is it three times faster?
No?
OK, it's actually four
times slower, approximately.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's a little
bit upsetting, right.
You remove the slow mode banner.
And suddenly it runs slower.
If you take the observatory--
remember, observatory
is a friend--
and we try to connect it to
the debug mode Flutter run.
it brings this
line in, that when
you run the application that
you can go to this address.
And you will get
an observatory UI.
It looks like this.
Observatory has a lot of tools.
And I'm not going to walk
you through all of them.
But right there,
there is the tool
that is really useful
for figuring out
performance problems.
Let me zoom in for you.
It's a CPU profile.
So if you go there, you will
see that most of the time
is spent in this function
that does our computation
of harmonic series.
And if you start
clicking on the links,
sooner or later you will be
able to reach the disassembly
for this function.
And I recommend learning a
little bit of ARM assembly,
maybe.
I don't know.
But there are a lot of just
human-readable English language
here.
So for example, if you
see diff and add and add
that obviously tells you that
some division and addition
is going on there.
So this is the loop
for our benchmark.
And you see that
the JIT compiler--
because the debug mode on
Android devices is using
the JIT mode of the VM--
was able to figure
out what we are doing
and produce a relatively
tight loop, where
all the operations
on the double values
are performed directly
with registers.
And everything is very
nice and beautiful.
And actually, if
you have a profile
like that where you just see
your computational kernel
and all time is spent in it,
it's usually a good sign.
There might be some code
quality issues inside.
But it's a good
sign that it's not
going into some strange
runtime routines and so on.
Now we want to figure out what's
happening in the release build
of Flutter, right?
Why is it taking slower?
So you cannot profile
the release build,
because it doesn't include
any development tools,
because you just want to
ship it to the people and you
don't want to ship
development tools with it.
But there is a mode in Flutter
called profile mode, which
is exactly release mode plus the
observatory and all required VM
side components.
And it brings the link, just
like debug mode brings the link
to the observatory.
So if you go to that link
and look at the CPU profile,
you discover that situation
in the ahead-of-time compiled
build is not very beautiful.
There is the
computational kernel
and then there are methods
of double being called,
which means something
bad really happened.
And if you look at
the assembly code,
then you will see that it's
coaling just directly methods
on double, nothing is in lines.
And the reason why nothing is
in line is because in Dart 1,
you cannot really guarantee
that the thing that is called
a double is a double, right?
It can be a dog, which is going
to woof when you add to it,
or meow when you divide it.
So the VM cannot really
produce any tighter code.
So, OK, this statement
maybe is not very true
if we are looking in the current
context for where Dart is used.
But strong mode to
the rescue, right?
Strong mode is going
to fix everything--
maybe.
I'm cautiously highly excited.
[LAUGHTER]
So if you take Flutter
from the tip of the tree
and then build
some stuff manually
and do some magic
invocations, you
can try running Flutter with
the completely new Dart 2
compilation pipeline.
And-- da-dum!
It actually runs
faster, almost as fast
as the JIT version is running.
And it's an ahead-of-time
compiled version.
So things are getting
really quite a bit faster.
Just a reminder--
the AOT version 1
took around four
times slower, right?
And if we look at
it in the profiler,
we discover that now
it spends, again, most
of the time in the
computational kernel.
And everything is in line
into it, everything is good.
And when we look at the
generated code again,
we see that there is some
directly-performed double
operations.
So that's good.
But there is some
strange code which
looks very ugly after
them, which was not
present in the JIT version.
So this can also be tracked
down to what's happening.
We just need to type
in this command.
[LAUGHTER]
And you can see the
intermediate representation
that our optimizing
compiler is using,
and figure out that there
is some work in progress
happening.
We're going to fix it.
OK, so what's the
moral of this story?
You should expect potentially
drastic changes in the AOT
performance
characteristics in Dart 2,
once we ship that completely.
And I think they
will be for the best.
So everything will become
much better than it is now.
And that's the
reason why I don't
want to give you any advice
now about the performance,
because things will change
so drastically that all
my advice from today is
completely invalid tomorrow.
But I will still
give you some advice.
And I think this
is the kind of--
how will I run performance
studies myself?
So it's very important.
If you care about performance,
performance is not an act.
Like, you do today performance.
And tomorrow you forget.
And you go on vacation.
Performance is a
continuous process.
So if you are running tests,
you should run benchmarks
in the same system where you're
running tests continuously.
So it's very important
to understand
what you are actually doing.
So you should understand
things in abstract ways.
Like, for example, if you
have a loop from zero to N,
it will take you linear time.
If you have two loop from zero
to N nested in each other,
it's a quadratic--
so on and so forth.
You should understand
that taking a substring--
in the worst case it
will be, for example,
linear by the length of the
substring in time and space,
and so on and so forth.
So you need to understand
abstract costs of operations.
You also need to
try to figure out
the implementation of
things a little bit,
like on the outer layers, and
understand the concrete costs
of individual operations.
Because somewhere
it looks like you
are doing something
that is linear,
but maybe underlying
implementation
makes it quadratic.
That's a real case.
Now, if we are talking
about GC, for example,
sometimes people don't
understand really how GCs work,
which is not surprising
because GC is very convoluted.
And even people who
implement GCs don't always
understand how they work.
But there is this
interesting thing
that you pay most, in terms
of the GC time for objects
that are middle--
they're not dying young and
they're not dying very old.
They're kind of in between.
And you pay most for those.
And as I said-- for example,
I showed this call side
optimization that we
do in the AT compiler.
So you can see from
that that, for example,
the monomorphic
call side is much
faster than polymorphic
or megamorphic call side.
So if you structure
your code in such a way
that you can avoid polymorphism,
that usually is good.
And it's good in any language.
It's not even limited to Dart.
So once you kind of understood
all of these things,
you start by applying
some abstract algorithmic
optimizations.
And just try to
reduce the complexity,
reduce the amount of
stuff that you're doing.
And then you start applying some
engine-specific optimizations,
which you derive by talking
to VM people, for example.
OK, so-- not really.
So I mostly focused on
the compiler in this talk,
right, because that's
what I do most of my days.
But VM is not really
limited to just compiler.
For example, there is
a garbage collector.
And VM uses a combination
of Young Space Scavenger
and Parallel Mark
Sweep, as if it's
telling somebody
something-- unless you
have read the big book
about garbage collection.
So I'm going to show you how the
garbage collection works, very
quickly, and why some people say
that this is good for Flutter.
So in new space--
OK, no new space,
let's say, like that.
So when you allocate
objects, what happens
is that we have some sort
of continuous memory buffer,
and a pointer in it.
And when you allocate
things, it just
goes and puts stuff in this
buffer, one by one, [INAUDIBLE]
and again.
And when you create a
closure it's also an object.
So it needs to be allocated.
And eventually it fills it up.
A surprising
thing-- that we need
to allocate an object when
you return a newly-created
double from a function.
And then when you've filled
up this buffer, GC comes.
The young space GC comes.
And what it does,
it says, I have
some other continuous buffer.
And I have pointers,
like some routes,
like static variables
and stack pointers.
And I look at what they're
pointing to-- these things are
going to survive.
And then I start copying
everything that survives,
and traversing the graph
and copying and copying.
And eventually I've
copied everything.
So everything that is not
copied just dies immediately.
There is no reason
to traverse anything.
And what was copied survives.
And the allocation
will go there.
And when this one fills up, it
happens again in the other way.
So you use the previously
emptied buffer to copy into it,
and so on and so forth.
This is what Scavenger is doing.
Then there is a
mark sweep thing.
In reality, you
have young space,
which Scavenger
manages and compacts
all the time by copying.
And periodically, you promote
things that survive too long.
Like, if it survived
several collections,
you don't want to copy it
back and forth back and forth,
again and again.
So you promote it in
some other old space,
which is managed by a much more
expansive garbage collection
algorithm, which traverses
the whole graph of objects.
I'm not going to
illustrate how that works
because it will take too long.
So one thing you should
have figured here
is that there is a relatively
fast scavenge phase,
but they're also expansive
mark sweep, potentially,
when the old space fills up.
So recently, we have implemented
something called idle time
GC, which is a collaborative
way of scheduling the GC where
the Flutter engine framework
sends signals to the VM
and allows to time
the GC in such a way
that the longer GCs that
operate on the whole heap,
they fit into the time when
there is no animation going on.
So the jank is reduced.
Then we also implemented
compaction, which we didn't
have for a very long time.
Like, if you go
back in the slides,
you see that the old
space, unlike new space,
is fragmented.
There are holes
between objects, which
means the allocation in
an old space takes time.
There is unused space,
and so on and so forth.
So the compaction allows to
reclaim this unused space
between objects and reduce
fragmentation and improve
allocation space
in an old space.
And it works very well
with an idle time GC
because the compaction
is a costly procedure.
But you can schedule it in such
a way that you cannot actually
see it on the animations.
OK, we have some work in
progress for 64-bit systems,
compressed pointers.
As you know, in 64-bit systems--
like iPhone is a 64-bit system.
Or if you're running
Dart on a server, which
I encourage you to do, they
usually run on 64-bit servers.
The pointers are 64-bit.
And of course, if the
majority of your heap
consists of pointers,
that's a lot of space there.
The compressed
pointers allow you
to compress the
pointers to 32 bits
and reduce the memory footprint.
Our preliminary
measurements show
that, for example, in
the Dart to GS compiler,
compiling some very
big applications,
you can save like 30% of memory
and make it faster, actually,
because the GC time is reduced.
So this is the real
thank-you slide.
So thank you for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
Before I get kicked
out from the stage,
I would like you to invite
to talk to us-- to me,
in particular, and anybody
from the VM team who is here.
I cannot see because of this
light going into my eyes,
but I ask--
everybody from the VM,
can you raise the hands?
And stand up even, yeah.
Can you stand up?
Please, stand up.
Don't be shy.
Yes, so there are some
people from the VM team.
Come talk to them and to me.
Yes, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]